hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast make sure you subscribe
so you get the videos
as they come out yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey hey hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage
it's a show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find out if they
grow up classy or if they're absolute
trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here in antoni's
basement
she's uh she's doing okay nothing to
report today
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of
ru garbage he cooks the books he keeps
the feds off our back
keeps the snow off our heads do me a
favor give me a nice big round of
applause
for kippy kevin james ryan hey hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and then patreon.com
are you garb you get bonus content uh
bonus episodes of ayg episodes of hard
feelings and every month we'll do a live
stream with the top tier members where
we play ayg with you guys you ask us
questions we ask you questions this good
[ __ ] time
get involved baby yes sir how about a
nice big shout out to our producer
extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy scene
our good pal
we know him as t-bone yeah but his mom
named them what
toby cornelius mcmullen what's up if my
mom named me cornelius i'd [ __ ] kill
myself
toby mcmuffin over there toby mcmuffin
toby mcmuffin is the t-bone mcmuffin ah
that's the new one right there that's
it right there well i had brass knuckles
out ready to defend the brand now i'm
putting them away
[Laughter]
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly incredibly
incredibly
special guest back with us here today
that's right gang
we got a little company it's a family
episode
and this guy is as thick as thieves as
it possibly can get
if you haven't seen this episode please
go back you're acting like you [ __ ] my
sister
i mean he's laying it on fit that's just
what he does
i'm trying to tiptoe into it a little
bit i'll be seeing you at thanksgiving
the name of this one's barry and the
hatchet
gang he is the co-host of legion of
skanks
he is the host of real ass podcast the
co-host of believe you me
all right he is the co-founder of the
gas digital network don't forget my
fourth podcast
yeah gomez talking to thomas talking
science fiction
watching seinfeld there we go very good
and of course he is the founder of
skankfest and skankfest south
do us a favor give us a nice big round
of applause for the suburbanite
louis j gomez everybody thank you thank
you i'm very happy shake your rattles
everybody at home
it's not a question if i'm garbage it's
really just what level of garbage am i
we know yeah we know i think you were
one of those you were one of the earlier
episodes that we did and i think you
were like yeah i'm not garbage
like i think there was part of you that
was like i'm not guard well it was
i mean i think that i've well it depends
on
are you currently garbage or or can you
jump out of the garbage class from
garbage to being classy
absolutely yeah you you're on your way
you're on your way but you're you can
only get so far
there's only so much money it's gonna
you've reached the height you're still
going to be treated
your vendettas really hold you back a
little bit the stink off of you yeah
that's
exactly you're like james will do way
better than you like james will be way
classier guaranteed because
yeah he's growing up a little bit of
cake college nice job
in the suburbs which is pretty nice yeah
it's not a bad life we talked about that
we love that your episode
was really really endeared me to you
and it was i saw it as not a victim of
circumstance but like when you told that
that race car story made me it made me
so sad
that like people were just shitty to you
just for the fact of it remember when
you were oh yeah
yeah when i was like which race car
story was like can i make up this
door i have no idea what either one of
you are doing
so when you were right
they got blamed for stealing them yeah
kind of because i have another i
i thought there was another uh p there
was another piece of blue shade gomez
trash history as well which involved
um remember in boy scouts you had to
make the card we just talked about these
last episodes oh yeah
the derby cars are there yeah and it was
just essentially a hunk derby or
whatever pinewood derby it's a hunk of
water
in the boy scouts i was in the boy
scouts my boys
my boy scout leaders was two moms it was
my mom
who was a heroin addict and then dan
doherty's mom who was like a religious
nut job
somebody stole all the badges and melted
them down and they didn't like each
other they like our boy scout leaders
were two chicks they didn't like each
other
we had this little weird [ __ ] it was
like out of a movie it was like all the
kids in our boy scout troop were gummo
every one of us we were just [ __ ]
different shapes and all weird
we've been directed by harmony corrine
dude yeah dude and [ __ ] uh that's
like a bad movie from the 90s
yeah you know that's that's like a
religious zealot and a heroin addict get
together to do the boy scouts
but that's the kind of [ __ ] that endears
me to you it's like you would think that
you were like this tough rough and
tumble kid
but you did like that stuff you wanted
that yeah you're a sweetheart you wanted
a normal
you like you're kind of a nerd oh well
yeah a little bit of a word you know
what it is i always appreciated being
different
so whatever it was that like the kids in
my neighborhood weren't doing or
the kids in school weren't doing like i
joined the drama society in high school
not because i like to sing and dance
like you do though it was but i do
you you flex at any chance you get i
learned that
i did but when i made the decision to do
it it was just because it was
weird for me to do it mm-hmm you know so
the house the pi uh the pinewood derby
okay
well you know you'd have to essentially
carve this block of wood
into a cool race car there was like
regulations the size and the wheels you
could use
you know but you know dads were helping
these kids out make these pinewood derby
cars
so they were super cool dude your mom
made a crack pipe out of it they did
they had [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you i don't even know
these dads did it i have no idea
how they did some of the things they did
with these cars but my mind was [ __ ]
blown
one kid and an acura and a hot meal
it was crazy and mine
we didn't even we didn't even carve it
down we just took the piece out of the
she was like just a log it was a [ __ ]
block it was a hunk of wood
we threw the wheels on it i painted it
it was a lincoln log
i would love to get a [ __ ] photo of
what that car looked like i had it for
years it was called skull crusher
because my mom used to hit me in the
head with it she just made a shiv
dude i painted it yellow and black and i
painted a little skull on it i put a
skull crusher on the side
and this thing [ __ ] sucked this was
it was so bad every kid had a cool
[ __ ] looking car and
here came my piece of [ __ ] car and i
remember they gave me a trophy
it was so sad because even i'm like
eight and i remember bigger
i know i know because it was the the
most imaginative trophy
[Laughter]
poor bastard award the the imagine he
had a father trophy
and i remember being like oh this is a
[ __ ] pity trophy wow
all my trophies that i've ever owned in
my ear in my ear and my entire life have
been pity trophies jesus christ
but if you would if you would have
applied yourself you could have been an
athlete
right uh i feel like you're i mean
you're athletic very uncoordinated
right not athletic he's not athletic
you're fighting what do you mean don't
say that
i i i've sort of figured out
how to like throw a punch and not be
punched sort of but not very well not
compared to people that are
confident you want going into a fight
that's what he learned that's what he
learned in the boy scouts
i just feel like people that really know
how to fight it'd be ridiculous for
because i know
people that really know sure of course
so it would be ridiculous for me to be
like oh i'm good at when i know exactly
how bad i am
okay because i'm better than the average
person if you haven't trained in martial
arts i could probably
do pretty well against most people right
um but anybody who's trained that's a
little bit athletic they're gonna
probably
i'm not very good oh man that is a
[ __ ] story and a half
yeah that's so funny you did all that
stuff the the boy scouts
what else did you do that that we
wouldn't know that people wouldn't think
you'd if you would i mean boy scouts
drama nobody
i would have never first of all and you
paint this picture of your mom
that's pretty good that she was a a boy
scout leader for a little while
she was hanging she was trying she was
trying it's more than my family did she
was trying well but she i mean it was
such a deficit my dad had been murdered
a couple years before that it's all
rainbows and
my mom was a heroin addict and like so
she was like when she tried she really
tried
yeah yeah she taught you how to tie a
knot and cook a spoon
sell some thin mints he'll be all right
that's the girl scouts
but there was a few yeah there was a few
years when my mom actually tried it's
not like she didn't
she tried to do some of the good mom
things she was still extremely abusive
and [ __ ] crazy and violent and you
know threatening
and all that other stuff but how was she
with the other kids in the boy scouts do
you remember
she was the cooler mom because dan
dory's mom was like a fat christian
[ __ ] so nobody
dude you want to go to church you want
to hang out a crack house yeah
easy choice any day of the week well i
remember you know there was one thing
where
we had to like put together like it
could be whatever it was just whatever
it was a big project we all had to be
involved with
and like one troop was putting together
the biggest gingerbread house possible
and the next trip was making like this
wood log cabin
[ __ ] thing and this [ __ ] she i mean
she had like [ __ ]
corn husk leaves that she was like
laying over sticks
and we were making little miniature
indian huts and all we got to do is take
a little piece of glue and put it there
and she was like all right next
move on and it was her project and i
remember just being like this [ __ ]
sucks
this [ __ ] blows yeah everybody's got
sweet ass [ __ ] around you
everyone's got cool [ __ ] going on we
have this [ __ ] indian hut it's gonna
be featured at bear mountain
your mom's project was safe cracking
yeah
doing a second floor job and i need a
wheel man my mom was teaching us how to
pick pocket people at the supermarket
oh good stuff well buddy thank you for
coming in and sitting with us uh we
wanted to have you back we like to have
our
have the guests back little family
episode have a little company um as you
folks know that when you sign up for
patreon you will get one of your
questions uh asked on the air
and uh we're gonna do that absolutely
right now yeah yeah
i don't know why i haven't added weird
words yeah you're really going like
morning news segment people think that's
what we're gonna get into right when we
get back they think i know what i'm
doing but it's a really
very thin line you really black out yeah
and just uh
i get lost in it yeah i got it i said an
incredibly short road yeah
yeah like today with the ant today intro
and teddy she's doing all right well i
thought i'd
less is more all right um being you know
obviously all you know a lot of people
know that you just got a new car you
just got your license and a new car yeah
yeah they got an audi yeah within a
couple days of each other
you bought the out he didn't lease it
right no i'm buying yeah you're buying
yeah now
what was the stow situation over in the
burp that's yeah did you have to shovel
it out
or does the i tried to find somebody to
do it for me
like there's no there's no little kids
that go door-to-door like when i was a
little kid i would hustle yeah dude i
[ __ ] went out there i'd knock on
every door in the neighborhood i'd give
them a crazy deal
because i didn't know how to place my
services
through the grass too that's crazy um
but nothing
i could do i called places all over
jersey to see if there's
only they only do commercial stone world
they talked about like i was crazy
really really you could get like a
landscaper we got a snowplow guy at my
mom's
yeah no i i called my landscaper to see
if he would do it he didn't get back to
me
geez he's probably busy out plowing yeah
um all right well this is from chris
uh do you brush the snow off the roof of
your car or you just let it blow
off as you drive down the highway i
brushed it's my new car
yeah so you have equipment to do that oh
yeah i got a big long [ __ ] brush in
majigger but i did with my hands at
first i just wiped all that [ __ ] off
with my hands and then i shoveled it out
and you did the driveway yourself oh i
do the driveway myself this is a tough
time i did not do
i did not do a path from my house to my
driveway
that's a trashy thing over the course
that's the trashy of the two-day period
me and my son just
our way through so now there's like a
path sort of but it's compe
that snow will be there to like march
yeah and the only problem with that is
when you when you when you make the
the foot indentation if it freezes that
night then that's a [ __ ] ankle
snapper right there well this is why you
can't go you don't want to just try to
go through because that's too much
it's too much what you got to do is the
first time you go or you go through the
next time
you step in between the other two
bookmarks you're connecting them
essentially you're connecting the dots
the third one you clean everything up
[Laughter]
and then you got a full path all it
takes is three trips you have a full
path
you and a family of four three trips
holy [ __ ] that's true that i mean that
is true not doing the
the walk is trashy yeah i respected it i
mean you did it in your own way
yeah where do you where are you throwing
the snow you're putting probably putting
it right on the street
are you doing it on the sides like
you're supposed to like throw it out how
big is your driveway by the way how many
cars you fix i got a two-car garage
you have a two car you park in the
garage no you got it you made it
a gym which is garbage yeah i got a new
audio that i'm like looking at like
every time it snows i'm like [ __ ] yeah
every time you've done a home
improvement to your house someone's
tagged us in it and been like is this
garbage and the answer's like yeah
every time he's got a trampoline in the
living room the gym is nice the gym
inside is nice fantastic you got the
sauna is that up running yet
it's not no you haven't yeah okay you're
not gonna be able to do it are you well
it's gonna change
the wiring it's gonna cost me a few
thousand dollars to do it and it's just
almost not worth it
there's a sauna on the corner like a big
like
european polish [ __ ] yeah oh really
you know steam song
nice it's like 40 bucks every time you
enter but i looked at
um but the amount of by the time i'm i
pay the two thousand dollars it's gonna
cost me
to make my sauna working i could
probably go to that place with the same
amount of times
without all the work when you say down
the street walking is there anything
walking yeah there's walking distance
places from your
from your house yeah huh i got a
supermarket walking distance
got a nice little sandwich italian
sandwich spot
in jersey it's hard to miss the best the
best sandwich spot i've ever had is
called um
a family affair that's so guido
it's a family affair they're [ __ ]
sandwiches jerk off that's all it is did
they name all of their sandwiches after
like [ __ ] italian movies
godfathers i guarantee you
whatever they're saying
whatever the father whenever the father
dies and those kids will be all fighting
over the business oh yeah well it's all
there's nobody nobody else works there
it's all family i kind of like that the
sister the one girl they don't let her
touch the sandwiches
they put her on the register like sorry
colleen you're working the [ __ ]
register you're not touching the meat
these brawls they don't know the
sandwiches it's the tiny brain
there's a but they're great dude they
close they close whenever they like run
out of their [ __ ] for the day they're
running out like cool
yeah dude they're not they don't [ __ ]
around on sundays it's like we got 300
rolls
first 300 that's the way that pizza
place in in uh coney island does it he
makes a hundred pies a day that's it
no more anyone i love it fully buys all
of
them
he knows everyone's name like the first
time i went there i was like oh what's
your name boom lewis
now every time i go in i thought you
were a cop every time i go in i tell
them i'm a cop
i walk around jersey like i'm a [ __ ]
cop but it's the best and i love it and
every time i have a a gathering your
friends over i just get those sandwiches
cut them in thirds
i i try this is how much i love them i'm
like i don't even tell them what
sandwiches i want i said i trust you
give me a variety
really yeah that's a man i love the fact
that you do that that's
i do do you enjoy the fact when people
come over that you're flexing on
check out do you tell them about tell
them about how they close when they run
out of bread every day
that's my go-to story with people
hey bobby wait do you get a load of this
place stay closed i got them they're
right there dude
they're right down the street right 24
7.
that dude bobby loves it bob dude bubble
bobby loves a good sandwich solid
but that place you know not to give them
an advertisement on this [ __ ] podcast
but they oh god they're in jersey man go
to [ __ ] a family affair
cut that out that's gonna be your uh
your dom's dom steak tips
yeah like bobby's hey gang just want a
quick reminder
about the stereo app it's a good time me
and the big man are on it and we're
taking your are you garbage questions
oh we're having a good time over there
on the stereo app
every thursday night at nine o'clock
being kitten eastern time that is
we're on there we're mixing it up with
you guys it really is the best way for
us
to interact with you guys yeah right
yeah get on there you drop a message
we're goofing around back and forth
absolutely fun absolutely great quality
on the app we're having a fun time there
come on in yeah check us out every
thursday night at nine eastern standard
he's always pushing with the new whip
are you smoking any yet no no no no no
you're not doing you're not
you're clean right well you know what i
shouldn't say i'm completely i'm not
drinking
but i've been smoking at night lately
yeah you know let your hair down a
little bit wait wait why were you
why were you off everything just
training just because i can't i mean i
need to [ __ ]
clear my mind i need to not be walking
around in a haze all day
okay so six months from now every cup
holder is gonna be full of blunt cuts
when i was smoking weed every day i was
i never even smoked wheat in my new
house
where would you smoke it outside garage
or outside okay yeah smoking weed in the
smoking weed in your gym that's classy
nobody's [ __ ] smoking weed in my
goddamn brand new car
[ __ ] crazy smoking james's bedroom
before that happens
leather interior i'm sorry leather
interior serious package
oh oh yeah of course what about the easy
pass i still haven't got the easy pass
because i haven't got my plates yet i
don't got my places i got a little piece
of paper plate
wait what you got the car like over a
month ago no a couple weeks ago probably
right i got the car on
[Music]
no it was maybe the 11th of january of
january yeah
so yeah going on that's fine they got to
mail out the plates it's a pandemic dude
yeah they love
jersey they do it all for you they
register it right there i gotta go pick
up the plates from the dealership
okay no easy pass though that sucks
i didn't i mean i'm embarrassed to admit
this but all through the pandemic i
didn't have easy pass
and they were just there's males to you
right i know but they were mailing it to
my car's register to my mom's house so
they were mailing it there and then i
just didn't pay i'm like oh it's 90
cents i'll get around to it i'll just
pay all of them
and i just didn't do it i owed like and
they just dude they would turn a [ __ ]
90 cent toll into a hundred dollar
no 90 cents if you don't pay it if you
don't pay it they hit you with 35 and
then two years later
it's a hundred dude i had to pay like
20. i haven't paid a single toll yet
get on it get on it and i go i drive
into new york city
sixteen dollars yeah that's something
that's the bridge dude the bridge will
be
close yet the bridge will end up costing
you like 125 dollars yeah
you're [ __ ] blowing through like a
ups guy jeez you feel right
i finally got i had to clean it all up
and then i got it yeah that's crazy
i feel rich with it that's how trashy i
am i drive through i still feel like i'm
getting away i throw the change in
anyway yeah yeah
thank you get out of here it's yourself
for life
bozo all right this is from uh huizhou
jared i believe is history hyenas uh
have you ever lit a cig in the parking
lot of a gym
cause i have and that is a garbage move
yeah for sure because you feel kind of
rejuvenated when you walk out
and it's like finishing a meal you're
like oh i need a bernie you know what i
mean yeah i definitely have
i i would i i've been in shape before
and been smoking cigarettes
smoked a cigarette right before a jog
right for a run
when i used to work at equinox we would
take cigarette breaks and smoke right in
front of the equinox
really come on in i'll give you a good
deal foley have you ever been to a gym
follow-up question
i've seen the commercials on television
or jim stakes
um all right this is from katie have you
ever bridge hopped
like jumping off the bridges into the
into the water i would peg you with that
guy that does that yeah
yeah see that's right new york and the
the penny bridge
and this they always have [ __ ] at
the penny the story was that they had
like they always have a myth too giant
planks of wood that were sharp you got
to not jump right into their three feet
area you had to hit yeah of course
otherwise you'll [ __ ] have your bend
your knees when you hit the water that
way your knees don't go to your [ __ ]
or whatever
yeah dude every town had that
we had the trestle and then like for
that was the bridge
and then there was like another level
that people called like air and crazy or
[ __ ] whatever
and it was just like literally somebody
broke their pelvis every year and they
had to get like drug out of the woods
there's a place called the deep hole in
your mom's house
and it was just a giant i've been to
that bar cold
spring it was like so cold on like a hot
summer day
it was [ __ ] crazy um but too cold
like you just like it was so like icy
like upstate new york mountain water
and there was these like just cliffs you
could jump off and
you could just see a giant boulder on
one side like if you hit that boulder
you're [ __ ] dead
but you could jump off from like one
ledge which is pretty safe then the next
one up it's pretty [ __ ] scary i'm
afraid of heights
and then it got crazy like kids were
jumping like the puerto rican kids would
just [ __ ]
do backflips like slow backflips what
the [ __ ] was that that's crazy
somersault
they have nothing to live for okay i
would go off the smallest one and me and
my friends were there one day just
jumping off the small one
and then these [ __ ] cute chicks
showed up these pretty cute chicks
anytime chicks show up and there's like
young teenage dudes that's how people
get killed hairy
that's right that's dangerous dude
they're wearing like they're wearing
jean shorts and a bikini top
i'm [ __ ] diving in dude it's over
that's exactly what it was
it was some [ __ ] chips holding your
arms back like that face first
daisy
super hot and we i i recognize that
we're [ __ ] like i was like alright
dude we haven't
been jumping off this little tiny short
one the whole time i was like let's just
[ __ ] go
yeah let's leave first of all we're not
gonna get these hot chicks we're [ __ ]
dorks
we're not getting them okay but let's
just go
because we're gonna look like [ __ ]
we're gonna work on our derby cars
we're just jumping off the short one the
whole time it's sad so let's leave so we
start to leave
and then the girls these [ __ ] pigs
they were like you guys aren't going to
jump off the high one
oh man they knew what they were and then
me i was like we've been jumping off it
the whole time
that's not even fun anymore why would i
want to do that we're going to go train
dodging actually
we're going to go rob a bank real quick
so then they're like yeah sure
and i was like what i'll jump over who
cares all right but i'll do it right now
i mean
dude i start climbing up the rocks and
right before i get to the port where you
have to jump off i lose my footing
and i f i tumble down the mountain
rocks i mean just do you know what it
feels like to just have your whole body
in just
a bathing suit roll down rocks and i'm
screaming
and scratching and crying it's holding
on to a tiny plank like a cat
trying to climb i tear my fingernails
off my fingers
my fingernails are just bleeding i fall
under the water the girls are cackling
crackling at me as i just float away
down this little [ __ ] weird stream
[ __ ] has never been dryer
oh my god did you get laid or no oh
please so can i get your number what's
the deal do you get the second base
i just think about the story that those
girls have they're laughing on a podcast
right now
you remember that [ __ ] loser remember
that pudgy puerto rican kid
do you remember how he almost died you
know he screwed the way he screamed
i'll never forget the tone of ice cream
i think i saw this tiny ball
through his swim trunk it was a goddamn
nightmare
oh that's [ __ ] vicious man
i never got that i was always petrified
of that stuff we used to go to a quarry
there was always a thing the fear of the
quarry the legend was you would jump in
and your legs would get stuck in the mud
that was like that we had a quarry as
well it was like you jump in you'll go
too far down
yeah your feet will get stuck in the
middle that was always my fear in the
bay
at low tide that you're that way you're
hitting your feet would get stuck in the
mouth so i don't [ __ ] with the bag
i'll go on the beach maybe a little bit
that's it i'm going to the bank
but we used to squeeze to do it at this
place called sladington and there was
one
same thing they were all these it was
actually looking back and it was
beautiful it was crystal clear water
because they were digging and they hit
an underground river and it was all
slate so it was all clean
and it was awesome but there was like a
40-foot one no big deal we'd all jump
off that
then there was like this 80-foot one and
it had like a thing that went out
and man one of our buddies went off it
and [ __ ] it was like
a body hitting the [ __ ] thing just
smashed on its side oh eyeball [ __ ]
popped out
oh oh it was eyeball popped out of his
head
ruptured his blood vessels in his eye
whoa [ __ ]
hurricane yeah passed out [ __ ] woke
up
and you're back there too there's nobody
coming that i don't think kids do that
now
well i mean i told the story i think on
here on my podcast about uh
my knee yeah skiing yeah no not skiing
you were jumping off of jumping jumping
yeah it was your podcast yeah uh yeah
yeah and i almost lost my leg from the
knee down and we were stuck in the woods
like a mile back
yeah and my my leg was just hanging off
of my
my knee was just hanging off from the it
was only connected by the skin in the
back
it looked like a shark but it was
[ __ ] vicious dude good times good
times shout out to the 90s [ __ ] out [ __ ]
with uh quicksand
no that that wasn't real super mario
hey pitfall take it at you ever have you
ever had a easy
attack you i mean are you ever trying to
cross a swamp and hippos start charging
you
i hear the most dangerous ones i don't
know why i just did louis voice
we played quick say this again where
where was your quicksand
africa yeah the amazon or the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i didn't know you were johnny
quest what about
banks of north carolina he's like what
you've never stolen a diamond from a
pyramid
stuck over toby's got a weighted bag and
a [ __ ]
what museum were you working for what
dick were you on
he's like what so i said an ancient
spell backwards all the dinosaur bones
came to life
you guys never fought what was the name
of your guys genie when you were a kid
i never had a weekend with bernie
wait i don't know it was a voodoo they
brought them back to life
no they didn't they
i think they use like chicken breast
instead of a live chicken or something
yeah they use kfc
yeah yeah and they [ __ ] and every
time uh they would play reggae music
it was a dance and they're like in like
2011 all day they were doing it in the
club they would go do the bernie
i don't think i ever saw that i don't
think you were in the clubs
when you guys were on my podcast i just
i was going skiing that week
yeah yeah which i i wanted to update you
looked you you looked the part i gotta
give you impressive
but i also know that you crushed it i
also am aware there was some video that
was not that was not aired
on network that you you might you might
have stepped stepped
over the line a couple of times you went
on some hills you maybe shouldn't have
yeah i was funny as i talk about it on
stage now but i got bullied by a [ __ ]
white guy i told you you're not gonna
mesh well with white skiers
no they wouldn't you don't have you you
don't have the hey my bad
[ __ ] vibe those dudes are upset
you're there and you're
party bro well no i got i went on the
wrong slope like
i was going down the green ones all day
and i was like all right i got this i
told you stay on the greens
i went down a blue one and i crushed it
but here's what happens okay
did you have poles by the way i feel
like you didn't have poles no i had
pulse pulses oh but i was just doing
some [ __ ] cell i was doing
you're not supposed to do it
stopping taking pictures in the middle
of the trail up next the flying puerto
rican
you're not supposed to do any of that
and uh he's on facetime making calls
just hanging out on the ski lift going
around why are you meaning that there
once two o'clock hits the entire
mountain turns to ice okay it's just
[ __ ] a whole sheet of ice
so it becomes a lot more difficult to
get down so i go down the one blue hill
i was like that was [ __ ] exhilarating
that was incredible
i'm gonna go down that one again let's
go and i took the
ski lift back up i took the wrong ski
lift because i see that one and i was
like
well that's gone now and i'm just going
[ __ ] up up up up
and um you know where you're supposed to
get off
the whole time i was getting off the ski
lift you get to the top it's flat and
you just [ __ ] go oh you lean forward
you go to the right you're like
look at that i just got off the ski left
a nice feeling this one when i got to
the top
it was a drop it was like this like you
had to drop off the ski lift and start
just
skating down this [ __ ] hell jesus and
i i just had never experienced that so i
looked at it i was like that's not where
i gotta go
i'll get on the next one so i just
stayed on the ski lift and then they
stopped it
yeah of course they're like you gotta go
there's a trigger you're not allowed to
go back down i want to go down
you're not allowed down you can't what
it's not a [ __ ] carnival right yeah i
know you're not supposed to
so they stopped it you could if you
would why am i i guess i could have
argued
yeah that like no i'm going back down
but i i mean i haven't skied in a while
but i used to
i grew up skiing and snowboarding and
when you go around it there's like a
trip
wire that automatically stops this oh
maybe there was a tripod
yeah you hit like one of those poles
that like falls so all i know is they
stopped it he was like oh you got to get
off
so i had to jump down now the whole
everybody on the ski lift you just hear
them doing that
oh come on let's go buddy come on
there's girls and daisy dukes laughing
hey it's the fat kid from the cliff so
foley i don't know how's your fingernais
loser i don't you you said you had been
skiing before you had i mean
minimally all right so you're probably
like me where you know i'm i'm
robust to a certain degree so i can't
get up with the skis on so i have to
take my ski off it's
very hot if you've never fallen in skis
it's very [ __ ]
i have to take
so then i get up and i'm like oh [ __ ]
dude look at this hill and it's crazy
i mean it's so steep by the way i'm just
right
in the past though they haven't moved
this i'm just standing there
everyone is just getting a lot of this
hill don't
they [ __ ] do they hate me so much so
i was like oh sorry so i move out of the
way and then these three guys get off
and then one guy's like hey buddy get
out of the way and i'm like i was like i
was like relax i don't know what i'm
doing
then he goes yeah obviously what a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's a great joke dude
that's a great response it made me
furious
that's so that is a [ __ ] home run
response
[ __ ] because he zips away in his
yellow coat or something
i was like yeah [ __ ] i was like
yeah come say that to my face
meanwhile you probably fell again no he
goes ski on or get peed on that's when
he said that line he goes
or get peed on oh that's a douchey like
she stopped it obviously
then i goes okay you want to pee on me
bro you want to pee on me
and then i fell and then they
laughed again and zipped down the hill
did a little ollie over here and then
what's [ __ ] up is like i
i was like [ __ ] dude i don't know how to
get down this hill so i start going down
and when you go skiing you gotta go side
to side right so you go side to side and
sort of that's how you mitigate your
speed
so my plan was i was like i'm just gonna
go to one side stop
one side stop one until i get smarter
smart way
is it you go you're going along my path
is the other blue hill that i had gone
down so essentially
it's just further up and see if you can
get to that one and i knew i
did that at some point once i got to
that one i knew i could at least handle
that but this was
really really steep so i start going
down and i wanted to stop but i just was
going too fast
and i'm not good at turning uh to my
left so i just hit that
and i started going straight down i'm
talking about like barreling um
so then you're thinking i'm going too
fast to make a turn and then you're just
[ __ ] so then i was like well i
obviously have to throw myself on the
ground to stop myself so then i said it
kind of ski on my side
and the skis they have a it's sort of
like made so they come off your foot so
they don't snap your ankles off your
body yeah
so it flew off my foot but it flew in
front of me so my body just
[ __ ] went boom right over the ski and
it broke the ski brake
so the ski brake was in position where
it wouldn't go up so
now if i try to skate my foot was
skidding yeah right so when i put it
back on
so i broke the ski brake back at the
other position so now it couldn't be on
so when i went to go put it on it
slipped out from under me and shot down
the hill
so i just watched this ski i mean dude
it was just going so
what i knew i'm on one [ __ ] ski i'm
just trying to get people to help me
come on give the [ __ ] out of the way i
saw the other guys they
may get me right down to the slope did i
saw this ski under get peed on guys
they'd come down another time
they're getting lapped on the hill and
luckily i just i could i found the one
the track for the one ski that went into
the woods
let me borrow your ski dude and i
tracked my [ __ ] ski into the woods
and i finally got it and was able to
were you scared at any point at one
point when i was up there i was like
[ __ ]
i'm actually going to be in trouble here
i was like because if it's like there's
nobody to help you of course
i can't get back up like i can't get
down it's not like you can get on
somebody's shoulders and ride down
no they send they send the snowmobile
for you yeah and then they pull you off
you couldn't walk down right
it was too steep to just walk down i had
ski boots on so technically i could have
like you know you're all like [ __ ]
walking like a deer they push you
forward
so i could have technically sort of made
my way down and you know slowly and
painfully i just want to slid down
did you challenge the ski owner would
get paid on guy to erase for the
ownership of them
no i didn't but i showed up and did you
see them again when you got down to the
lot
no i didn't but had i seen him you would
have would you have definitely said
something i had no more confidence left
in my life
what was your girl doing doing all this
[ __ ] she was taking a ski lesson
uh so she was just [ __ ] it was with
this old guy though i i didn't have to
worry about it
it was some [ __ ] couple of ski
bunnies on the hill yeah a couple
[ __ ] yeah she no she i was better
than her i was pretty good i'm i'm
actually pretty decent at skiing
but i wouldn't pick her as a skier i
would beg her yeah
all right this is uh this is from joshua
do you consider craft singles cheese
are you a craft singles guy you probably
grew up craft singles
no because we were too poor we were
shoprite american yellow american
so we just get it by the pound like your
mom would go yeah yeah we go
give me a pound of yellow american um i
i don't really consider
american cheese cheese much less craft
single it's not real cheese
well why don't you take that commie [ __ ]
yeah it sounds like some european
[ __ ] if you ask me
i'm a big craft singer what do you do
what do you what do you do with jane
what would be a typical lunch james is
home
daddy i want lunch so we were snowed in
for a couple days we went right i went
to the supermarket
yeah it's the [ __ ] back i did get
lunch meat nice some turkey
i got some ham i got you you [ __ ] with
uh jason buffalo chicken the buffalo
chicken
he doesn't know about sausage sauce same
[ __ ]
it's just a better version it's i think
it's the boar's head version blazing
buffalo is sausalito no the
boar's head is blazing buffalo okay so
whatever it's a little bit different
sauce look up sausalito yeah so that's
nice
turkey they're blazing buffalo's
chickens yeah oh you do the sausalito
turkey
i'll give you that that's in the same
wheelhouse very nice classy delightful
so i didn't do that no i just got
regular turkey got regular ham i got uh
cheddar cheese
what i did was i did a slice of ham
slice
of uh turkey two slices of cheese
put it in the fryer make it like a
grilled cheese hot meat grilled cheese
sandwich european style and the fryer
you know frying pan oh okay
grilled cheese with some meat on it
you're under selling the sausalito
because it's blazing buffalo but it's
bold sausalito turkey damn he just
one-upped me
what the [ __ ] what's the what's the
bread situation what are you using over
there
15 grain okay not good you two would not
you really
[ __ ] and you put them on the cheddar
no american so you're not getting no no
you won't let him have craft singles i
mean if we if we're it's not like i'm
like no you can't eat that i just would
never buy it
hmm what about the cereal fancy taste
so for him i just he does like oatmeal
and [ __ ] he'll do like you know
some cream farina cream of wheat [ __ ]
like that that's this
dude that's it sucks because like
growing up i would look at those kids
like that [ __ ] stinks but that's the
right play
otherwise we're [ __ ] cereal guys he's
gonna grow up to be better
lucky if i try to get my kid lucky
charms he's like dad what are we doing
here like he's a little
really stinky you get my oatmeal
he looks at that as like a treat like
dessert you know but he's just you know
he's just got way better way better
habits than we had that's good like i
didn't even have lucky as a kid like
lucky charm is by far the best if you
try to say something different we got
problems
big fan big fan not a fan i got to say
not a lot of lucky charms love that
version
how is that even possible well we're
irish and we thought it was racist the
whole time so we weren't allowed
it's my father on a cereal box is there
an elephant one full we can get mad
the hamburger's last name was vazquez
[Laughter]
real rude we were at coco pebbles house
for sure cocoa pebbles
honey nut cheerios baby honey nut
cheerios there was nothing wrong with
the classic that's because he was trying
to
pretend he was healthy my mom was still
done but my mom knew that we were two
my brother were only two years apart we
were both animals
if a box of lucky charms came into the
house at two o'clock on a sunday when
she got back from the grocery store
it would be gone before dinner yeah
that's why much has changed apparently
but it's like five [ __ ] balls of
cereal i mean i can eat five balls of
cereal in one sitting right now yeah
at this point honestly where i'm at
weight wise so if i have like an edible
or something in me
i can easily eat a box of cereal in one
sitting
yeah i mean that's not shocking to
anybody i wasn't trying to shock anybody
just the abcs of me baby
have you ever put honey on honey nut
cheerios yeah
i put syrup on it too what what not
recently
[Laughter]
it's pretty pandemic at least i mean
that's kind of crazy honey nut cheerios
putting extra sweeteners on it well
that's why
we've come to the conclusion on the
podcast that's why i'm fat is because
it's never
it's never enough for me it's always got
to be something else
i have to add something to it you know
like i'll have to dip my chips
in like honey mustard ice cream or
something rather than just have the
chips it's also portion control let's
not be like ah it's the toppings or
trees it's the condiments yeah it's the
honey i put so much
i put so many chopped onions on my hot
dogs too much mustard
i've put so much muscle to my 15th
hamburger guys wrinkles i'm telling you
they're gonna be the death of me
these crew times are destroying my life
all right
all right uh this is from chad have you
ever walked through a drive-through
yeah absolutely oh yeah well you learned
the hard way that it's like weight
sensitivity yeah like jumping up and
down on it
maybe you're like yelling at it and
you're gonna run up to the window
they're like you need a car it's like
come on
what do you [ __ ] care for why do you
care
i don't know why i hate when the guys
care why would they hear them are you in
it that they're caring
i hate multiple stories steve back there
again
doggy we used to drive to go to the
because the drive-through's open late so
that's
that's it you know and when i didn't
have a car at certain times in my life
simple as that you got to go get some
fast food get some mcdonald's yeah i've
taken tap back in the day before uber's
like i was in college in philly
we would oh that's the test take a taxi
oh
don't turn the meter on i'll buy you you
know what i mean like i'll buy whatever
you want i'll get you a hamburger
yeah but when i live you can just do the
loop and operate the [ __ ] out when i
first
when we first moved up here i was living
on 35th street in astoria boulevard
there's a burger king right there i
would get off the astoria boulevard exit
like [ __ ] 11 o'clock at night [ __ ]
zero money
getting our dick kicked in [ __ ]
starving and i would walk up to the
burger king and i'd walk up there with
like three dollars
and at the time they had like you know
like you know bacon cheeseburgers for
like a dollar so i try to get like two
of them
there was this one kid that would play
ball and so i would have to [ __ ] like
stand there
and watch the cars go by and look in the
window to see if he's in the bushes
is it clear is it clear he's yelling at
his manager look he set the sensor off
put a license plate on my forehead let's
give me the fry's [ __ ]
but sometimes they wouldn't do it and
that it you think
that the the level of humiliation in
that
is [ __ ] astounding when there's cars
behind you
and you're getting shot down at the
drive-through yeah oh you're doing it
when there's other cars there yeah well
i'm in line
have you ever standing in line have you
ever gotten like a nine piece chicken
mcnuggets and they give you eight you're
like
i gotta go back now and ask them for the
other single chicken mcnuggets you take
your loss
you'll go back
i went to a diner the other day yeah i
went to a diner the other day with my
son and my chick
and we ordered breakfast and my uh i
ordered uh this isn't three eggs
they gave me um what is it uh where you
[ __ ] get the eggs and the hollandaise
sauce over there thanks benedict eggs
back i got a ben i got a benny right
you look at you dude i wouldn't even peg
you for someone
not like just knowing what the public
knows about you like first glance i
would be like he doesn't even know what
eggs but
let's do this by the numbers it's crazy
[ __ ] house in the burbs
audi audi [ __ ] good you gotta get got
a good kid on his hands
trampoline in the front yard trampoline
side yards
[ __ ] eating eggs benedict so they i
don't have the confidence to order eggs
and the water the eggs were too watery
so i went into it and just like exploded
with like just clear liquid everywhere
it was sickening so i sent it back and i
was like that's the way they're supposed
to
get poached eggs no they're not supposed
to eat they're still clear like the
clear
jizz you don't want the way you want the
yellow you want the yolk to be [ __ ]
i've had a mcmuffin before this is not
right so i said i was like hey
you do them um you know medium this time
or whatever
so they gave it back to me now there was
two pieces of [ __ ] ham on each piece
the first time this time it came back
one had two pieces of hand the other one
had one piece of hand
oh my god i was like excuse me miss oh
my god
oh you're the worst dude i was like i'm
missing one of my pieces of ham on this
piece of eggs benedict she's chewing it
[ __ ] that dude i pay for that [ __ ] i
want every single bit of it then how did
you tip
are you a good tipper i'm a great tip
yeah i could peg you as a guy i'm a
great tipper but i [ __ ]
i i start to they start off at 25 and
then it goes down from there it can go
up from there too if it's incredible
service
now is she losing points for that she
didn't make the eggs
it's how they handle the situation how
did she handle it
she handled it fine she was cool fine
she was cool
she was like i'll be right back we had
another food on the table it wasn't
really a problem did she get to 25.
she might have gotten more like 30 yeah
i gave her 100 bills 75 dollar bill
is that crazy breakfast is 75 75 for
eggs benedict though we're not talking
french toast do the fresh squeezed
orange juice do you get
do you guys get something to share like
some pancakes to share so yeah i usually
get some yeah some things some silver
dollar pancakes to share
corned beef hash to share maybe some uh
grits
then we all order our own entrees and we
pick off each other's plates
but i love it ah i love it
i like flavors i like it i like i like
[ __ ] flavors
okay i like that that bothers me that's
it too many flavors
no to everybody i just want my things
yeah my girlfriend
do my girlfriend [ __ ] you you get not
wanting to share
she straight up so she had her she
ordered like avocado for toast and my
son was like
hey can we like share me with your son
and she was like you gotta kick this
[ __ ] to the girl she said no
this brawl's gotta go i swear to god
it was bonkers yeah honestly that would
be a deal breaker it was bonkers that
bothers me
she's like i just don't like sharing
food and he was just like no
you're kidding right dad who invited
this brawn
i couldn't believe it he could not
[ __ ] believe that she would not share
her food she was like i'll save you a
piece
i don't [ __ ] it especially to a little
kid yeah
he was like i really like her but you
know the fact that she doesn't share it
that can i talk to you in the garage
stingy bra it was
it was borderline sociopath behavior
yeah that's not good man
seriously that's not a red flag that's a
major
red flag at least blame it on the
pandemic or something like hey we're not
doing that during the pain
that's what i've been doing okay first
of all he's a [ __ ] little kid
he doesn't need it he's got the corned
beef hash and the seven dollar pancakes
this kid gotta have everything on the
menu it's important it's important
you see there's a line here now kevin
ryan gets it
i mean some people are like that they
just don't want to they got their thing
they don't want some of your thing they
don't want to share
that's not that's i'm a sharer i'm like
we're like family style like everything
it's like i get a little piece of yours
you get a little peace of mind yeah you
got to try everything
every time that's why i love eating with
my girlfriend i don't share food
every time like i think i think you're
getting the better end of that deal
every time
and then well i'm like i was like yeah
i'm gonna get the steak with it she was
like i'm gonna also get the steak i'll
punch her right in her [ __ ] cheekbone
he's like no we are sharing you're gonna
get a different eye my wife does
my wife can order whatever the [ __ ]
she's paying for by the way she can
order whatever she wants
because she's picking up the bill i'm
gonna order whatever she'll be like do
you wanna do this this one will share
that it's like
no i want a whole thing of ravioli
you're saying it right now like your
eyes are rolling into the background
picturing that's crazy dude
i'm picturing us one night we went to
this place called twisted oak in uh
terrytown very nice it's like a [ __ ]
five-star restaurant very expensive and
i legit ruined dinner because i wouldn't
share with her
wow my what was it yeah yeah you made
you guys both ordered the same thing
because you didn't want to share with
her something like that it was something
and like i legit ruined this like 400
dinner i legit ruined it what the [ __ ]
wrong with you shut up
she tries to get two cherries in my if
she tries to get the same thing as me i
legitimately have a problem with it what
are you doing like we're not getting all
the flavors that we can get right now
every
the fat guys at the table have a
different attitude i do it with the
other tables too what do you guys get
i'll get this you're done with that i
got a whole system
have you when's the lat because i know
the answer is yes when's the last time
you ate food off of a stranger's table
when they weren't either weren't looking
they left a diner
when we were kids we would [ __ ] do
that all the time he got fired for it
not too long ago
no when i was waiting tables that was uh
all the time
all the time all the time even on his
days off
come in and see what's good what's this
special tomorrow i'll see you at noon
let me put it this way i put the food
down a minute later i'm coming back you
guys all done with this
okay you said he's having a pretty good
where he would recommend [ __ ] for the
kid kids were the best to eat off of
and he would recommend you that he
should try the calamari or whatever
but in reality the kids kids kids and
adult men
if they weren't attractive i wouldn't
eat off their plate but if it was an
attractive guy or an attractive girl i
would
but kids i know those chicken fingers
they got boogers on them oh yeah they're
picking them up sucking on the end
putting it back yeah they're doing
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] yeah and it's also
depends on what it is you're not gonna
eat like a half-eaten burger
for some
we'll be right back after these words
from the stereo app
i will either if if an attractive
businesswoman comes in
and cuts her birthday i think part of
this is sexual because it's always based
on their appearance
she's got if she's got something [ __ ]
on yeah i have a bite of her hot dog
she's in a tree uniform a turkey club
and they got
you know a [ __ ] a triangle with one
untouched or whatever yeah like yeah
i'll eat that
i'll do it right now i'll eat that some
chicken fingers some french fries i
completely get it that's not
hang on i want to get back to this real
real quick i just want to touch on this
um i don't know how how sensitive of a
kid james is
but if he's a little sense like you know
if he picks things up
i bet you that [ __ ] really bothered
him and probably made him feel
he is a sensitive it probably made him
feel weird man like that that that's not
a
because because you know and just like
as a girlfriend you want to like not
impress but you want to like
you know be a part of the family or
whatever that's a real [ __ ] red
you know what is i had to separate
myself from it just because i'm just not
that way
but then you talk to somebody like kevin
who's like they get it
and some people do how about this they
don't want to switch
they don't want to put you don't put
your fingers in my food don't touch my
food they have their own food i won't
share a drink yeah i mean dude if he
i can't even eat in front of him anymore
i'm just saying from a child's
perspective i feel bad for james
he's very he's very smart he's not he's
not like uh he don't think he's carrying
it around
because that would bother me they've
hung out since he [ __ ] loves her yeah
that would bother me for a while she's
[ __ ] look she jumps on the trampoline
with him it's all right
okay all right hmm i got more upset
about it you really did
yeah um i know you have a history with
um cab drivers have you ever falsely
recorded
an uber driver for texting while driving
to get a full refund on your trip
or anything of that nature no but i have
if they forget
a ketchup packet and my uber eats i will
pretend that five things are missing
and that the driver threatened me
and he wouldn't share with my kid well
oh so you'll do that to like cash in on
like a free chicken sandwich or
something yeah because you'll just like
say all right
you know the condiments are important
okay so let's say they forget the hot
and sour sauce or whatever it is right
you're like okay now i'm just supposed
to not enjoy this much and if you
complain about it they go okay
sorry but it's not the uber no dude this
guy falls it's not coming out of his
it's not coming out of his end you're
sure yeah yeah yeah it'll go like a
store
yeah the store will go like oh we'll
give you a free burger or whatever yeah
it's not
he's not he's not in the kitchen
preparing the food he's just picking i
know that's what i'm saying it's a
staple bag i don't think i've ever used
ubereats i just i've used seamless yeah
seamless is only a new like a new york
thing though
and not not everywhere has seamless so
in this so in the servers
when you call to get something delivered
it's not the pizza places delivery guy
it's an uber driver i mean you think
they have delivery guys at these places
yeah most of them are just
uh so they just subcontract it out to
each other i don't like that man i don't
like it i don't want i don't like to
think of an uber driver
bringing my food to me it's a delivery
guy i don't know
it's it's weird he doesn't have any
accountability because once he's gone
he's gone
you know look if i'm an uber driver i'm
eating one third of every
piece of food that comes and they've
caught people do the one guy was
drinking a milkshake and put the little
straw thing back on oh did you see there
was pictures of the guy with like the
seamless bag or the uber eats bags in a
public restroom who's taking a [ __ ] and
he had the bags
in there with them so you just see his
pants down at his ankles and then like
two
two mcdonald's bags see that's what i'm
talking about whatever
at least the guy who works at the place
he knows he's accountable yeah
yeah he can get yelled at by the boss
yeah for doing whatever
i was a delivery driver for a hot minute
when i was younger i was a pizzeria
driver
pretty if it was actually not a bad gig
yeah got the windows down couple of
seats yeah a couple of bernies yes i'm
learning some skinner on the radio
talking about good [ __ ] clean living
right there um all right on a few more
this is from simon in the facebook group
have you ever taken a picture in front
of someone else's car
no that's so [ __ ] garbage that's
sickening
i saw someone do it like grown-ups dude
we were in wildwood a few weeks ago and
there was like you know a lamborghini or
something parked and this like grown men
pulled over got out of their car and
took a picture in front of somebody this
is how we're living one of those yeah
just like yeah check it out i'm like you
could just google that picture as well
and also have it there's no need for it
to be
i think those things i think those cars
are loser anyway i'm being
not because i can't afford them but i
think there's a certain
level that you stop at i wouldn't want
to be driving around in a lamborghini
like a [ __ ] loser
like an orange lamborghini like these
dork straps money wasn't an
object you stopped i'm telling you i
swear to god it's not the money you stop
at an audi you stop at a benz you stop
at a beamer
something like that no that's what
you're driving every day but you just
i mean dude i'm thinking about buying a
nice convertible like an old classic
convertible this summer
just to drive around what are you doing
i like it this guy's got cash and he
knows how to spend it i'm just saying i
want to [ __ ] have a nice convertible
driver
or something i don't even know what my
mom had that's why i learned how to
drive in shout out to a [ __ ] red
sebring convertible
lewis and a miata but if i had if money
was on the way doggy
money wasn't an object i would get a
[ __ ] porsche or a lamborghini just a
[ __ ]
just a [ __ ] richard just to have who
gives a [ __ ] it's just a toy
it's like i have a [ __ ] oculus that i
never use only just made he can't fit in
it
yeah i would be able to finish i would i
would get the magnum ferrari that's as
far as i would go
i don't even know what that is magnum pi
oh okay
this guy i'm like i'm out of i don't
know [ __ ] about cars i literally don't
my car just stopped working right now
like i don't know what i would do
take it to a mechanic i don't even know
how to get it there let's not work on
the ubereats guy
yeah yeah yeah i'm majorly [ __ ] like
yeah i think i have triple a i don't
know it's like a hundred bucks a year
you gotta order it and you pull over
even if you if you get
if you [ __ ] your car dies you just
[ __ ] call it up and they send someone
to come get you
sure and most insurance plans might have
i couldn't even
find my registration card or insurance
card in my
i don't know what either one of those
are like if they were like license and
registration
i wouldn't they would think that i'm
like doing crazy [ __ ] i was like sir can
you help me
i don't know there's some papers here
and i'm pretty sure it's in one of the
envelopes it does
sometimes amaze me how successful you
are and the things that you don't know i
don't know i don't know
like i myself were talking about this
the other day um
i don't like if i got a flat tire i
still don't know if i have a spare
and you have a doughnut problem i have
no idea yeah
audi might have a full spare but it's
also this is uh this is why where is it
it's under the trunk
yeah there's like a little a little knob
you'll unscrew the knob and then it's
like a false bottom
how can you not know that i don't know
that's why he's successful though
because
this doesn't bother him like he doesn't
it's not occupying his mind
if i got a flat tire he's only got so
much [ __ ] ram space in that head
the [ __ ] out on the on the side of a
road somewhere and start screaming
you see the tire irons aren't for beeps
and uber drivers
so i have this weapon that came in the
back
they're not as good as they used to be
anymore uh because it's like a part that
connects to the
to the jack it's all one it's one one
piece i just had to change
my tire a couple months ago yeah i don't
know how to do any of that stuff but i
mean i figure it out let me have a
figure that's pretty easy yeah you're a
smart guy
yeah all right couple more here this is
from brian uh
do you now that you're a big drive do
you draft behind a truck on a highway to
save gas
what is drastic [ __ ] talladega get
behind them [ __ ] is doing
yeah yeah how much money could that
really say now over the course of your
life the
dangerous act
just go underneath them like that yeah
you're talking to a guy who's pinewood
derby car was a block he doesn't know
that sounds like it's extremely
dangerous and not worth the
pennies per year that you would save
yeah it is funny some of the things
people do that they think they're really
saving so much money
it's crazy i don't do anything to save
money i i i literally i
none of my time during the day is
thought about money i buy the more
expensive the premium gas i don't know
why
you should probably for an hour you
probably should i probably don't know
why i have no idea why i just do it
sometimes on like a holiday i'll fill
mine up with the 93 just to like treat
her a little bit
she's had a rough life she only she
doesn't have that much longer i think i
got to make her enjoy your last i think
that's actually not good for
whatever either i don't i have no idea
the difference i have no idea what
one is versus the can you check your oil
you don't even know if he has a [ __ ]
tire
cut for three weeks do i need to check
my oil already
no but do you have a sticker of when
you're supposed to change the oil every
ten thousand miles
ten thousand can they say for something
should be every five thousand
they say three thousand but that's big
oil that's a big difference here's the
thing it depends they now have synthetic
oil which gets you a little bit longer
which is five
thousand regular oils three thousand
well i got the synthetic just because
that's how the car is made i would
assume you're either way i'm five
thousand miles over my dude
my current due date i gotta be honest
with you whether they're pouring lucky
charges i paid i paid for them you know
they was it a new car or certified
pre-owned
it was uh pre-owned yeah uh
but it only should have just said new it
had four thousand miles on it
yeah it's like a demo car it was the
loaner it was the loaner car so nobody
owned it
so that's not bad so people treated it
it looked brand new it was
a ten thousand dollar difference between
yeah growing up my buddy's family owned
a car dealership and
from 16 on he would just get a new car
every like three months yeah and he
would then they would he would get a new
car he'd put like three thousand miles
on it
and then they would sell that as the
death oh the deal with a dealer demo
yeah
so he would just have a new car every
[ __ ] three months pretty sweet
um all right let's see when was the last
time you wore uh
no socks with sneakers do you do that
are you
are you a pure sock guy i mean i'm a
pure sock guy
like in life but like i have thrown them
on to run outside or yeah
yeah are you doing slippers are you a
slippers guy at the house now i know
my i have a robe and i had slippers i
don't know where my slippers went after
the move
but isn't it crazy my robe is too hot my
robe is [ __ ] like thick
i want one of those like geisha you know
what i mean like like real like silk you
know like a hotel room feels [ __ ]
[ __ ]
japanese
i got my wife in a suit just walk into
the room and drop it yeah
um have you ever worn flip-flops with
jeans
yeah yeah that was that was big slide
100
oh you'll do like the adidas i would do
thongs i would do no socks for a while
but then i dated puerto rico she's like
no you got to put socks on i was like
isn't that garbage
and i think what on the flip-flops
that's a real garbage
socks with slides or how cool black
people do it yeah
if you're a brown person and you do not
have socks on and your toes are out
yo [ __ ] you nasty put your toes away
but white people your if you wear socks
with slides
then your white trash [ __ ] like you
know dad getting the newspaper off the
front lawn
so yeah it just depends on the the race
i always thought that was a prison thing
that people in prison they wore slides
and socks i mean you're gay or not
i don't know i thought that's what i
always saw like when i watched like uh
locked up or whatever
yeah i think that's i mean i don't think
it's a fashion choice in jail
no yeah i think it's pretty trashy
all right let's think of a go let's get
it going here to end on
uh this is from nick parker uh was your
first time getting drunk on wine coolers
if not what was it it's a great question
it was well yeah mine mine too it was i
just got
swine coolers it was wine coolers and
like malt liquor
but it started off like six or seven
wine coolers yeah it was a new year's
eve
party next door my uh in the 90s
probably late night yeah i was in the
seventh or eighth grade holy [ __ ] if you
look up
what year california love by tupac
came out like the world premiere of the
video was on new year's day
this is the the day after i got really
dropped it was something else
that song that video was bananas it
would make me nauseous for
years after goddamn seagram's wild
cherry
dude
it would [ __ ] me up dude because i got
so drunk
at my friend gano's party kano was uh
she's a puerto rican kid ghana what are
you
[Laughter]
do you speak spanish fluently no no but
they were barely speaks english
what are you talking about they they
worked on amiga
that's how you have to say his name you
can say miguel that was [ __ ] crazy
dude my dominican buddy
is he's his his first name is the the
vietnamese last name
win like the n-g-u-y-e-n i don't know
why this
his mom named them that but and they're
like proper to like from the dr
so they just call him gujan so his name
is his name is spelled win
but it's good so he's a good it's so
funny
i'm like i've met him i was like joe his
name and i'm like what's that and like
i saw his name like dude your name i
don't know if anybody's broken it to you
in 20 years but this isn't your name
that's not your name dude
all right good stuff louis thank you
thank you for having me the folks out
there to know that you got coming up
um yeah just uh check out the pods i
host a bunch of podcasts the newest one
is gomez watching seinfeld they do with
my sister
who grew up real trash um we gotta get
we gotta get
uh her on an episode of this yeah for
sure i'll confirm everything i've for
sure for sure um but yeah that's uh yes
because can subscribe to all the stuff
that i do on itunes and everywhere else
but gasdigitalnetwork.com is a place
where you can grab
everything ad free and uncensored all in
one place of course
buddy thank you so much kippy what do
you got for him as always please make
sure you review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and uh
patreon.com
and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media excellent t-bone thank you
so much louis
thank you so much for coming in coming
back what a family
we love you guys we'll see you next week
hey gang just another quick reminder
about the stereo
app tell them kids thursday night
straighten them out god damn it
straighten them out every thursday 9pm
me and the big men are on there and
we're taking your garbage questions it's
fun
people are calling in you leave
voicemails we chop it up with you it's a
good time we did well over an hour last
time
we're doing it live baby we're doing it
live you join in with us you can join at
the beginning at the end
whatever it's a good time i think you
can go back and listen to them so it
doesn't matter yes you can yeah it's
awesome so get involved go to stereo dot
com slash kevin ryan or
slash h foley you sign up we get to what
our beaks a little bit it's free to sign
up it's free to sign up so just download
the app
get involved baby do it it's a great
time check us out on stereo we'll see
you there
thursday night peace